thank you to target for supporting pbs
in 1519 the bohemian count hieronymus
schlick discovered a rich vein of silver
near his estate
and decided to mint his own coins named
after the valley where they were mined
these joachim stallers or toddlers for
short
became so popular around the world that
the word became synonymous with any big
silver coin
from the italian talero to the ethiopian
telari
to the american dollar but why would an
english colony use
dollars instead of the currency of its
motherland pounds and shillings
well during the 1700s london was intent
on keeping as
much gold and silver in the country as
possible they actually outlawed the
export of their currency
even to their own colonies that meant
that american colonists had to rely on
silver dollars from
other countries and the most plentiful
supply came from mexico
just south of the border spain was
producing vast amounts of silver coins
at the casa de modena de mexico
still operating today as the oldest mint
in the americas
officially called pesos these silver
coins were worth
eight reals which is why you might have
heard pirates call them
pieces of eight r but to the american
colonists they were simply
dollars no one knows for sure where the
dollar sign
came from but two of the leading
theories involve
the peso one is that the abbreviation
for it
ps became scrunched by hurried
bookkeepers over time
another suggests that the symbol refers
to an image on the back of the coin
a pillar of hercules with a banner
wrapped around it in an s
shape still coinage in the colonies was
hard to come by
what little there was went to europe to
pay for imported goods and it rarely
came back
in 1729 a young printer saw how a lack
of currency in philadelphia
was stifling the local economy prompting
him to write an anonymous
pamphlet called a modest inquiry into
the necessity of a paper currency
this was the same man responsible for
many famous financial quotes like time
is money and
nothing is certain but death and taxes
yep
it was benjamin franklin franklin's
advocacy of paper currency
earned him contracts for printing money
for the pennsylvania colony
but the english crown saw this as a
usurpation of its authority
by 1764 the british parliament had
outlawed the use of paper money in
america
just one of many stubborn decisions that
would eventually provoke the colonies to
rebellion
but to finance a revolution you need
cash
so the newly formed continental congress
authorized the printing of
millions of dollars of continental
currency
originally these continentals were
valued at one to one
spanish dollar but as more and more were
printed their value fell
dramatically if you've ever heard the
saying not worth a continental
that's where it came from though the
american revolution became the first
war financed and won with paper money
the american people felt
totally burned the founding fathers
decided to avoid the controversy
altogether
by not mentioning paper money in the
constitution at all and it would be
almost a hundred years before the
federal government
would print money again with the coinage
act of 1792
the united states officially made the
dollar the national currency
instead of the confusing british system
of pounds
shillings pence and farthings the dollar
would be
neatly divided into a hundred equal
parts which thomas jefferson suggested
they call
cents after the latin for 100. thus the
american dollar became the first
fully decimal currency in the world and
the new coins were struck in the
first federal building in america the
u.s mint in philadelphia
which predates even the white house and
the capital looking at these coins today
the first thing you might notice is what
they're missing famous people
america had just dispensed with monarchy
and elitism
the founding fathers wanted the images
on their money to represent
ideas not people so when did that start
to change
the same time we started printing money
again the civil war
before we get there we should introduce
an important but little-known figure in
american history
salmon p chase yes that's salmon
like the fish it's biblical
salmon was an anti-slavery senator from
ohio
who earned his reputation as a lawyer
defending black fugitives
from being shipped back to their captors
in the south
salmon had his eye on the oval office
for a long time
but in 1861 salmon lost the republican
nomination to the more moderate abraham
lincoln
who went on to win the presidency as an
olive branch to the radical wing of the
party
lincoln made salmon his secretary of the
treasury and it was under salmon
that the treasury started printing paper
money again to finance the union army
as ambitious as ever salmon decided to
put the face of his ideal president
on the first american one dollar bill
his own
the treasury printed over 400 million
dollars worth of paper notes which came
to be known
as greenbacks because well as with
continental currency greenbacks
depreciated as more were printed
at one point only worth a third of their
face value
as bad as that sounds it was a lot worse
in the south
the confederacy printed more than twice
as many of their confederate state
dollars
the value dropped so precipitously that
by 1865
a 10 confederate note would only get you
one or two cents worth of goods
incidentally this bill printed in
louisiana was commonly known as a dixie
thanks to the french word for ten some
people think that's how the area around
new orleans got the moniker
dixieland and how the south generally
became known
as the land of dixie neither dixies nor
greenbacks could be exchanged for gold
and silver
their value was based on the promise
that the government would redeem them
once their side won the war with the
north's decisive victory
confederate dollars were suddenly
useless scraps of paper but the
greenback
became such a trusted standard that most
people
didn't even bother redeeming them and
america finally became a land of
federally regulated paper money
ironically in 1870 salmon chase
now a supreme court justice claimed that
the federal government
had no constitutional right to force
people to use paper money
effectively ruling against his own
actions as secretary of the treasury
i'm sure it had nothing to do with the
fact that his face had recently been
removed from the one dollar bill
and replaced with george washington's
the ruling was overturned a couple of
years later but salmon would eventually
make his
final mark on our currency when in 1918
his portrait was used on the ten
thousand dollar bill
the largest intended for general
circulation
the next great leap forward for the
dollar would be thanks to
you guessed it another war
america emerged from world war ii as a
major global power
its economy was perceived as so strong
and stable that
in 1945 the u.s dollar replaced the
british pound sterling
as the world's global reserve currency
basically this meant that banks and
governments around the world
kept more u.s dollars on hand than any
other foreign currency
and used it as the metric for their own
currency's value
throughout the 20th century the
connection between gold and the dollar
got weaker and weaker until it was
finally severed
by the nixon administration in 1971.
the us dollar is now a fiat currency
meaning
its value is based only on the people's
faith in their government
while that sounds risky it actually
gives congress more
power to deal with economic crises as it
did just this march
by printing extra money as a response to
the coronavirus pandemic
it's probably not a coincidence that
over that time we started to see
more and more faces on our money faces
that inspire trust and confidence in the
american system
they're mostly ex-presidents and
treasury secretaries though not all
and the final decision goes to the
secretary of the treasury
with the only guideline that they beat
persons whose places in history the
american people know well
however in honor of our anti-royal
origins
living people are prohibited from
appearing on u.s currency
in 2016 the treasury department
announced that it would unveil
a new 20 bill in 2020 which would
replace andrew jackson with the famed
abolitionist
harriet tubman making her the first
african-american historical figure to
appear on federal u.s currency
don't feel bad for old hickory though he
was vehemently opposed to paper money
so he probably wouldn't have wanted his
face on the bill anyway
however in 2019 the trump administration
announced that they would be delaying
this change by another
10 years at least as americans we tend
to take the dollar for granted
almost like it's an unchanging natural
phenomenon like earth air or water
but like any human tool it was designed
for a purpose
and we constantly shape it to meet the
needs of the moment
it can cause stress and greed and misery
but also
hope and progress and prosperity without
the dollar we couldn't have declared
independence or eradicated slavery
the more we understand it the better we
can control it
so maybe the next time you use a
greenback you'll think of the long
journey it took
to end up in your pocket and that's our
two cents
we'd like to thank target for being a
proud supporter of pbs
since the first target opened in 1962
their mission has been to help
families discover the joy of everyday
life in all 50 states
target is dedicated to being a good
neighbor and working with their
communities and partners to make life a
little better
there are over 350 000 team members
employed by target to continue their
mission
every day to learn more about target's
commitments you can check out target.com
community or click the link in the
description
pbs is asking you to share your stories
experiences and ideas on your life in
america today
pbs american portrait is a nationwide
storytelling project
a chance to be seen hard and to give a
glimpse into your own life
everyone has a story share yours at
pbs.org
american portrait
[Music]
you